well and of course the first topic in
the football world today relates to the
reason why
we are in bad moods more often than we
are in good moods the conscientious
decisions
made by players to not play football at
all
in 2020. there is still at least a one
week window
for players to make final decisions but
some are already
doing it remember the seven day clock
does not begin to tick
on the final yes or no irrevocable
decision to opt out until they put
signatures on the revised collective
bargaining agreement that's still not
done
yeah so the seven day window hasn't even
started yet for some of these guys if
you're in camp
take take your time this is a big deal
because you cannot come back
the way the nfl has set it up once
you're gone you're gone and i've had
some thoughts about whether or not maybe
they should revise that maybe like
around halloween or something maybe
there should be a window
for guys who have monitored the
situation and realized hey the nfl is
doing pretty well
maybe i'm comfortable going baseball
player do it yesterday right i mean
yeah right right and and why should it
be why should it be speak now or forever
hold your piece for nfl players i think
they're trying to create a situation
where
fewer will opt out because the
consequences of opting out
are so clear and permanent at least for
this season but notwithstanding the
current status
the fact that the window still hasn't
opened on the seven day period
before opting out some big names
yesterday
joining the list and i was stunned
damian williams
the chiefs running back has decided to
opt out now again
it's a personal decision and we respect
each and every decision to opt out
that's made
but when when it's the closer it is to a
quarterback
the the more jarring it is right chris
like running there hasn't been a
quarterback yet
running back because yeah yeah we get
caught up in fantasy football and those
are the guys whose names get called all
the time because you get the football in
your hands even if you lose three yards
your name gets called and we're aware of
who you are and damian williams had such
a great role
down the stretch in super bowl 54 to
help the chiefs win the game
there's been talk about him and clyde
edwards hilaire who's going to get more
reps well
that debate is now moot because damian
williams has exercised his option
to opt out and in comes clyde edwards
heller a guy you and i
were both bullish on yeah before the
draft
and brett veach the gm of the chiefs
told me on pftpm
when he saw that we both had him where
we had him
and our mock drafts each had him going
to the chiefs with the 30-second overall
pick he pointed it out to andy reed and
he's like people are starting to figure
this out
but they still were able to get him at
number 32 and
uh that they're they're i'm sure at this
point happy that they made that pick
if damian williams isn't going to be on
the team this year no doubt i mean
you're right it's jarring i mean you
know listen our last memories of
football are damien williams running
down the left sidelines to put the super
bowl away right so
you know you're spot on with the guy
that's closer to the quarterback and
offensive weapon
fantasy football we saw a lot of great
plays through the playoffs
so everybody knows them now you know
this is these are the type of guys i
feel bad for i do
you know this guy that's had a rough
road in the nfl you know different teams
even college football at oklahoma had
some issues there
he's finally in a spot where you could
say oh he's comfortable look he's going
to be the starter yeah they drafted a
guy he'll split reps blah blah blah
but he hasn't made a ton of money over
his career and obviously there's
something about this situation that
doesn't make him feel safe
and you know as we know running back at
this point of his career what is he in
seven
year seven mike or eight am i somewhere
in that category
where this is efforting this yep this is
the guy though that i you know i look at
and go man this is a
a year wasted at the end of his career
and i don't mean wasted but
i worry about where he goes from here
and then
you know the clyde edwards hold on a
second let's let's let's go down let's
go down that route
for a second yeah because i wonder
whether and to what extent
some of the players who are opting out
view this as
basically a one-year advance on their
inevitable retirement like
i won't play this year which means i'll
play one year longer
than i otherwise would have played now
that's obviously not going to be
a hard and fast rule because you have to
have a team that wants you to play for
it on the back end right but we see guys
like frank gore and adrian peterson
getting work every year
at a running back position you avoid a
year of wear and tear
i i think it's not crazy to think hey
you know i otherwise would have played
until i'm 31
now i can play until i'm 32 because i
avoided an entire season of getting
banged up
well there is certainly some logic there
but you're also losing an
entire season of oh hey you know your
father time as we know is undefeated and
every year you go
goes by you're going to get a little
slower a little less strong
you're going to recover a little less
faster when you're beat up and things
like that so
that's a balancing act and mike i've
thought the same thing you have maybe
that's what guys are thinking
you know i'll do that get a little money
this year save my body
i don't really feel comfortable with the
circumstances this year
and i'll be ready for next year i'm not
mad at him i'm certainly not
i just look at situations like this when
you're in the year seven eight
nine in your career you know at first
sight and you're playing running back
and you're beat up that way
and you know he's making not big money
but two million dollars
hey i mean those paychecks are gonna be
hard to find you know as we go down the
road in damian williams career so as a
player they're just there
i mean listen it's it's dicey that's all
i'm saying
but the good thing is like you said they
drafted clyde edwards hilaire i mean
that i mean first off
you know like joe burrow in a lot of
ways mike you know joe burrow came from
a professional
offense at lsu with joe brady west coast
offense
and we talked about hey yesterday west
coast offense he's with zach taylor
that's a west coast offense that should
be good well clyde edwards hilaire from
lsu
west coast offense andy reed west coast
extraordinaire
so you know now they're gonna have to
put a little more on his plate but
he will be ready to go and mike he was
my favorite interview in the pre-draft
process
and i just know from a number of teams
talking and
talking about this guy and it shined i
thought even just when i got to talk to
him
he's a he's a man's man he's very mature
for his age
and i think people loved his attitude
and work ethic and knowledge of the game
and all those things and that's probably
why kansas city loved him and i think
he's going to have a huge role now
now i mean huge be the go-to guy
damian williams was undrafted out of
oklahoma in 2014
this would have been year number seven
for him he turned 28
in april so he was getting as running
backs go
closer and closer to the end of the line
and i think for running backs it's less
about
father time and more about how banged up
you
get in your early to mid 20s that that
influences how long you can sure
continue into your 30s
maybe damien williams can trade 2020
for 2023 or 2024.
we'll see and here's another angle chris
and look i'm i'm kind of spitballing
here i just thought of this while we
were
uh talking about it which doesn't say
much for my pre-show preparation
but damien williams like anyone else
who's making this decision
i assume it is a stew of factors it's
not a
simple binary am i opting out
solely because of the covert 19 panda is
that the only reason or
other reasons going into it how much
money am i making that's got to be a
reason
how much you're leaving on the table is
a factor in whether or not you're going
to play
if he was making 10 million this year
chances are he's not going to opt out
he's in the range of 2 million
more likely to opt out i wonder if
the decision by the chiefs to draft
clyde edwards hillaire and essentially
faze williams out was a factor in his
decision
to opt out this year i just want i mean
how could it not be it would be a factor
for me
sure you know you're making this big
decision are you going to play football
this year yeah and hey i want to be
there for my team but it's like hey they
went out and drafted my replacement you
know i'm not going to shed any tears for
the kansas city chiefs
i'm not going to go above and beyond i'm
not going to i'm not going to accept
this risk
all in the name of helping the team
chase a second super bowl ring
i'm out i just i have to wonder at some
level was that part of his thought
process and i think human nature would
suggest it is
yeah well i mean i i i get that i do
but you know at the same time i you know
i would argue and where you got to be
careful there again is
you know i believe he's going to make
two million dollars this year
you know that's that's that's not going
to be easy to find i mean i think that's
the big thing am i am i correct about
that i just want to make sure i got that
right
but effort yeah i think it's 1.2 million
actually somewhere in that range uh it's
been
messed with on on spot track right now
so that's why i'm not
exactly on the numbers but i think with
with that you know mike yeah i'd be
worried
1.85 million 1.85 million man that's i
mean
in year seven in your career undrafted
you know that's pretty damn good money
you know that's where i would worry
about it and then i would worry about
this too with damian williams i'm sure
yes he's not happy about it
but at the same time kansas city's
offense
if we play football just uh hold on let
me just check oh it's still going to be
really good
okay i don't give a damn who's not on
the roster
and now yeah you got clyde edwards lair
and all that and they got de'andre
washington
from the raiders and free agency and i
would just worry that the offense
continues to get better and better and
looks great and then they're just going
to go okay damian hey we loved you and
everything like that but uh you got to
find a new team next year
that's the risk some of these guys are
going to be you know messing with
and and i'm certainly not rooting for
that i don't want to sound like that or
anything like that but
uh i just think that's a very re you
know realistic
thought in this situation going into
next year especially
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports